every season it just feels like we're
getting more and more anime being
released last winter and more shows than
I ever remember in a single season and
out of the insane choice of 54 shows to
pick from I watched a total of two shows
from Japan and one from Hell more
quantity doesn't necessarily mean we are
getting more quality is what I would be
saying if it wasn't spring 2023 baby
just what is going on this season we've
got this show and this show and this
show oh God this show looks good too
wait ashinoka became the top rated anime
with just a single episode there's more
Gundam there's more Magus Pride more
ranking of Kings My Girl Mega Man is
back there's even the best fantasy of
all time airing
Demon Slayer the season is so stacked
there's even an isakai I'm not gonna
watch I'm not even gonna give it an
episode there's just too many shows to
get through you see I'm just gonna X out
and put on another shot just watch I'm
gonna do it I'm I'm doing it
[Music]
God [__] damn it
hmm
lesbian ladies
the era of gay girls in anime continue
and they're not even trying to hide it
anymore they've now made an entire Cafe
with the premises that the girls Yuri
beat each other in front of the
customers who get to discuss live if
they got a thing for one another like
they're an average Bocce The Rock fan
this can't be a real thing in Japan is
this a real thing in Japan if so I am
disgusted mortified if someone could
just leave me the name and address of
such a place if it exists just so I
could personally tell them how disgusted
I am at the idea that would be fantastic
but before you do that I've got a new
name for you honkai star rail today's
sponsor that's gonna send me down
goddamn rabbit hole and sponsor aside
being real for a second here guys I've
been so hyped for this game to come out
for months this is a brand new
free-to-play RPG developed by hoyoverse
the makers of Genji impact so you know
you know I was gonna be all over this
but even not knowing that honkai star
rail is a new fun and addicting
multi-platform game that you can play
anywhere anytime whether it be on your
phone PC this game is absolutely
gorgeous with cutscenes and combat
looking like something right out of a
big budget animated feature I see Hoy of
us have been spending my Primo gems
wisely in the game Trailblazers can
experience the joys of perusing sci-fi
masterpieces and explore the
meticulously constructed sci-fi world
through multiple Side Stories and Rich
in-game lore there are many powers and
races that come together in the Sci-Fi
epic across the vast universe and it's
all here waiting for you meet with tons
of potential waifus and husbandos listen
to their tables develop their ability to
fight create a formidable team and
embark on an epic space journey
Adventure who knows you might even come
across a familiar sounding NPC that's
right me and the trash chase boys have
joined the honkai star rail roster by
voicing a few characters so you know be
on the lookout on your first playthrough
also I'm gonna be a judge for honkai
starrell's first ever creates
competitions look forward to more news
about that soon so what are you waiting
for download the game today via the link
in the description and get an extra 50
Stellar jadege using the redemption code
on screen thank you to honkai starrell
for sponsoring me today and with that
said back to the video
like a star okay
no all right I'm over some turn your
brain off trashy wish for filming an
anime but what is this chubby kid gets
bullied and beaten up finds a door to
another world gets ripped overnight
starts high school the next day suddenly
becomes the popular kid the bullies
don't believe it a hot rich girl
suddenly shows up and asks him to enroll
in some prestigious school goes on some
dates becomes a model some princess
proposes to him and as the cherry on top
he gets to rub it in his Bully's faces
this isn't an anime this is a [__]
Darman video even by isakai Sanders this
is such a Shameless power fantasy that
it makes all that happen look like a
trusted news source good thing I'm above
this kind of thing
[Music]
a gamer who's hot dresses well interacts
with girls and touches grass now I'm a
gamer not because I have a life but
because I choose to have many and this
kind of representation is just setting
you actually it finally feels like we're
getting more old-school Shoujo romances
with a female lead but God damn is this
girl a hot mess a girl so painfully
desperate for love gets broken up with
trauma dumps on some random strangers
starts obsessing over her scumbag ex
gets blackout drunk with a guy she
doesn't know and throws up in his
apartment plans some dumb Revenge scheme
shows up at unannounced intoxicated my
boy just wants to play some goddamn
League of Legends I don't know how guys
but it happened we found a girl more
cringe than a gamer who slept with the
most people hey I'm trying to sleep with
everyone on my dorm floor do you want to
come back to my place oh my God holy
[__] but what happens when we try mixing
Gamers with girls that's right gamer
girls honey new neckbeard wife who has
arrived introducing hot on asan gamer
girl she doesn't go outside she hates
interacting with people she's a gamer
not because she doesn't have a shower
but because she chooses to
she doesn't have any
odor does nothing but play video games
relies on her handling for everything
transforms into this goddamn Gremlin
mode where have I seen this before Oh no
go back go back
[__]
oh
[Music]
it's beautiful leave it to Japan to be
able to make a romantic comedy between
the popular girl and the choir kid in
class who literally fantasizes about
murdering his classmates including said
popular girl in class I don't know how
to describe the premise of the show
without making it sound edgy and messed
up but this is a genuinely cute and
fluffy show yeah sure he might have had
some intrusive thoughts about murdering
a girl or two but my fellow gentlemen
know history has proved there's only one
pickup line that has actually worked on
your crush it's an invitation to my
birthday tomorrow I hope you'll be able
to make it to the party
why
I'll kill you we've got a crime Thriller
where our father discovers he's living
every dad's worst nightmare finding out
your daughter is dating that guy from
every NTR hentai you've ever seen so
what's the solution he comes up for this
predicament
dude what the [__]
that was a perfectly good rice cooker
magical girl Destroyer he is an action
epic where the world has outlawed the
biggest threat to modern society
weebs fighting against depression with
their fellow brothers Gamers as they
combat the onslaught of the uwu army our
protagonist the otaku hero The Reluctant
leader of the resisting weeb Army on the
classic hero's journey with trials and
tribulations where before he learns how
to run a resistance faction he must
first learn how to run a [__] bath
for real though why is an anime about
weebs rising up unironically going this
hard someone must have looked to trigger
an old school Guyana accent went let's
add weaves to this and you know what
they're goddamn delivering I never
thought I'd want to see guren Lagan with
weaves but this is it this is gurn Lagan
with weaves that's right I'm a weeb not
because I don't have [__] but because
I choose to have many imaginary ones if
you work out because you want your body
to look a certain way you don't care
about health you are fat phobic
you're telling me the concept of this
show some Jim bro enters a wizard school
and beats up magic nerds with the power
of muscles and benching it's [__]
Harry spotter the boy who lifted this is
like if Black Clover and one punch man
had a Hogwarts flavored baby God damn
why is it so much fun look at the
average beta magic users oh look at me I
Can Do Magic oh one one Guardian Leviosa
[__] that [__] [__] muggle
psycho 100 coming through showing these
Wizards the magic of muscles you're a
giga Chad Harry dead Mount death play
I'll be honest with a name like this I
was immediately ready to write this off
but God damn it it doesn't suck the
episode starts and you're like great
another generic fantasy anime but wait
no it's actually a reverse EC guy in the
modern world wait there's actually some
kind of death game with a murderous old
school yandere and wait it wasn't the
hero that got easy card but the final
boss of the fantasy world wait and it's
written by the creator of bakino and
okay okay you know what I'll bite I'll
give this one a chance
[Music]
all right what's next
you know I'm actually disappointed in
this one with the kids in the eye anime
about some girls attending a bee
trooping Academy there was so much
potential to make this an interesting
exploration of the world of youtubing
and streamers how do you become a
competent streamer how do you get on the
top of live stream fails how do you
craft the apology video that comes
afterwards but instead they decided to
make another Bare Bones generic Idol
show and you know what do we really need
another Idol anime oh yeah Idols baby
let's go this is a good [__] ah ah ah
all right real talk and I've watched and
formed over a lot of less than great
anime in my life I know I'm the garbage
isekai man I know I run a podcast
literally called trash taste but if
you've ever trusted me before if you've
ever gotten just one good recommendation
for me if you could choose one time to
blindly listen to me this is it when I
say watch oshinoko do not read the
synopsis don't do any Google searches
don't even watch my previous video on it
just go into it blind the this is not
another Idol anime this is not another
happy-go-lucky romantic comedy it's an
unfiltered look at the ugly world of the
Japanese entertainment industry from
deep within it from Idols to acting to
YouTubers to freaking cancel culture it
is Black Mirror for the modern
influencer landscape the hour and 20
minute long episode one will tell you
everything you need to know about what
you're getting into and whether this
show will be for you yes you heard that
right an hour and 20 minutes that's not
an episode that's a freaking movie but
it shows how much expectations the
studio put into this this has the
potential to match or even surpass AKA
akasaka's previous work of kagia Summer
and that is already an insanely High bar
to meet you might laugh you might cry
you might even find yourself going holy
[__] but what I can promise is that it's
an absolutely wild ride right from the
start and yet somehow this isn't nearly
the only thing I'm excited about this
season
in the anime arms race of finding the
next big Shonen battle show the
millionth fantasy isekai or another
feel-good slice of life even if there
are plenty of bangers in their
respective categories we can sometimes
forget the excitement of seeing
something new and fresh but that's
exactly what tengoku damakyo is doing
for me with thrust headfirst into some
post-apocalyptic world there's a
close-up facility with some kids a
deadly disease ravaging the population
Whispers of doppelgangers that exist in
the world some teenagers are searching
for a place called heaven then on top of
all this nightmarish creatures wander
the world at night looking to pick off
some unsuspecting prey you have no idea
what the rules are what's happened a gun
gets pulled and people are like mate
that's a toy gun what are you doing
today we're going to talk
how we can find out and how much we can
find out who knows what they're capable
of how much do we want to find out is
that even a real gun the more you [__]
around the more you're gonna find out
foreign
God damn they found the [__] out this is
not a series that treats you like an
idiot we're not given any Exposition or
explanations we have to figure out bit
by bit what's going on what's happened
here with the pieces we are slowly given
it's been a long time since I genuinely
did not know what to expect from a show
or where the story was going and that is
so goddamn exciting and on that almost
movie level Productions and a soundtrack
by chainsaw man and Devilman crybabies
ushio kensuke and we have a recipe for
the Dark Horse Contender for one of the
best shows this season but you know what
the hype chain doesn't even end there
skip to loafer is like if they made an
anime adaptation of Journeys Don't Stop
Believing and is one of the most
feel-good things to come out this Spring
PA Works a bit on a tear recently of
doing weirdo [__] so it's nice to see
them doing something simple again and
still hit out of the park they don't
need some Maids warring in Akihabara or
Chinese General being reincarnated to
Shibuya this time it's just the
struggles of a smile Town Girl moving to
the big city and adjusting to daily life
and I am here for it I genuinely haven't
seen an anime that's made me feel this
homely for a while there's this
authenticity to it I can't quite put my
finger on but every single second of
this radiates the positive energy that
will leave you beaming by the end of
every episode PA Works absolutely nailed
it whatever it is good animation good
characters just Good Vibes all around
speaking of Vibes we also have
insomniacs after school or not
degenerate call of the night sometimes
you watch a show that just captivates
you for no other reason other than you
Just Vibe with it so goddamn hard and
that is insomniac's after school in a
nutshell there's no cliche tropes no
overplayed archetypes no dramatic plot
lines just two human characters finding
a human connection than discovering this
pure joy of just hanging out together
the atmosphere perfect the writing
perfect the music Perfect The Good Vibes
I've got to say in all honesty
um
it's perfect the show felt so genuine it
almost made me want to shed a tear it
made me nostalgic for situations I've
never experienced yearn for my teenage
years that I can never reclaim again
beyond their shared common ground of
having trouble sleeping it's just a
treat to find a pair of characters that
have such amazing natural chemistry
together and you feel such a delight
whenever they're both on screen I've got
a good feeling about this one guys I'm
telling you this one's gonna be the
sleeper hit of the season
gay girls
all right that's enough good shows this
season there must be some bad shows I
can talk about
this is not it from one of Chainsaw
man's tusky fijimoto's assistant comes
hell's Paradise a bunch of death row
convicts get shipped off to a mysterious
place where no one has ever come back
from alive to bring back a mythical
elixir of life and the prize if they're
able to make it back
[Music]
um
tip
I see I think Suicide Squad meets Hunter
Hunter's Dark Continent are you got this
Mysterious World where the rules don't
make sense and the more you explore the
more you realize everything and everyone
seems to be hell-bent on killing you
after this some bloody action with a
side of edginess and you got a recipe
for a good time for us I mean not not
these guys I don't think this is gonna
revolutionize the industry or anything
but at the very least it's gonna be some
violent pretty looking action-packed fun
with a bunch of Larger than Life
characters
[Music]
gets transported to another world with
the sister thirsting all over the main
character oh thank God boys we did it we
finally found a bad show
why why does the incest Bay sister you
see guys still look like it has good
production values what is going on this
season to him mom one hit sister what's
next zero head daughter Hannah meets my
studio are you photobomb what about this
the hero is already dead sounds like a
generic fantasy I'm sure he can't have
anything cool
[Music]
God damn it is there anything I can drop
this season [__] it let's add another
one to my list you know I'm a suck for
interesting easy car ideas and this
one's pretty unique son of a cult leader
dies I need to find himself reincarnated
to a world where the concept of God
doesn't exist
me after watching unikai's dog and it's
up to him to start a new religion where
his power levels directly correlate to
how many followers he can get because
you know what what if you were
transported to a world without religion
where you were the sole person that knew
God existed what if you were the only
person who could hear God's voice and
you knew it was your responsibility to
bring their teaching upon the world for
the greater good what would happen if
you found out that your almighty God
was a lolly
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much this month to Alpha
Sigma author Curtis Eckstein basil
dysfunctional degenerate flabberwocky
ivito lovados
misaka12315 Payne Patchett Tony Stark
Water Guys VT and everyone else on my
patreon for helping to support me for
this month and making this video
possible I'm gonna be honest I hope you
have time in your lives guys because I
don't know how I'm gonna keep up with
all the great anime this season you know
I normally like to focus on new shows
but I barely talked about all the
sequels this season I'm also going to be
watching so where the hell am I going to
find the time I think I realized I was
going to be in for a rough time after I
did my spring anime chart stream before
normally that stream goes on for about
four-ish hours uh this season it went on
for seven hours just because there were
so many shows I was interested in the
season anyway though that's it from me
good luck to you guys watching all the
anime I've been gig up and I'll see you
all next time